en un vídeo anterior trabajé con este
ejemplo del problema de estadística ap
que está aquí y luego le pedí a personas
que están familiarizadas con el tema
incluyendo algunas que han calificado el
examen de estadística ap que lo
revisarán y señalaron algunos problemas
que tuve en la forma en que escribí las
cosas así que en este vídeo voy a
corregir esos problemas en lugar de
simplemente rehacer el problema todo el
ejemplo de nuevo de la manera en que se
obtendría la máxima puntuación en la
prueba p pensé que sería aún más
instructivo mostrar donde me equivoqué
las matemáticas en este problema no
fueron incorrectas pero si en realidad
estuviera tomando el examen de
estadística a p con relación a las
condiciones para la inferencia donde
teníamos esta condición aleatoria
establecida aquí me dijeron que cuando
hice el ejemplo solo señale la parte del
problema donde nos dicen que estamos
tratando con una muestra aleatoria
establezcamos que es razonable suponer
que las 65 cajas compradas por los
estudiantes son una muestra aleatoria me
dicen que a los calificadores ap no les
gusta esto
no quieren que solo apuntes a la parte
del texto en la cual se menciona que es
una muestra aleatoria en cambio lo que
podrías decir que es funcionalmente
equivalente pero quieres asegurarte de
que estás haciendo lo que la gente
espera lo que podríamos hacer es
escribir se establece en el problema que
se ha tomado una muestra aleatoria y eso
sería suficiente en lugar de dibujar la
flecha hacia esta parte de aquí este
punto ya lo resolvimos ahora la otra
cosa que no hice lo hablé en el vídeo
anterior pero no lo escribí y realmente
quiero mostrar lo que tendrías que hacer
en el examen ap real dije que no pudimos
rechazar la hipótesis nula y por lo
tanto no hay suficiente evidencia para
sugerir la hipótesis alternativa pero
cuando realmente estés tomando el examen
ap necesitas ir más allá
necesitas establecer una conclusión que
responda a esta pregunta específica del
problema con base en esta muestra existe
fundamento para la creencia de los
estudiantes de que la proporción de
cajas con cupones es menor a 0.2
así que voy a establecer la conclusión
relacionada a esta pregunta no hay
fundamento para la creencia de los
estudiantes de que la proporción de
cajas con cupones es menor que 0.2 y la
importancia de eso es mostrar a los
calificadores que has realizado todo el
proceso para lograr responder a la
pregunta espero que haya sido útil